nous recevons Simon Legault et les
météorologues pour Environnement Canada
monsieur Lego bonsoir
bonsoir donc je le disais environnement
Canada a confirmé qu'il s'agissait de
tornades quels sont les facteurs
monsieur Legault qui doivent être cochés
pour qu'un phénomène météo soit
officiellement une tornade même si on le
voit sur les vidéos qui sont diffusées
dans les médias sociaux
pour avoir une tornade la définition
d'une tornade c'est une colonne en
rotation souvent ça va être accompagné
d'un nuage parce que de la conversation
de cette rotation là et ça doit
s'étendre du nuage jusqu'au sol des fois
on parle de nuage en entonnoir parce que
ça descend du nuage mais ça se rejoint
pas nécessairement jusqu'au sol donc la
tornade doit vraiment toucher au sol et
quand elle cause des dommages comme on
le voit on le voyait sur les vidéos un
peu plus tôt au niveau de
Ottawa avant qu'on puisse confirmer on a
vu les dommages qui étaient causés
vraiment on avait ce nuageux qui
descendait jusqu'au sol donc c'est ça
qui nous permet de confirmer
immédiatement une tornade pour la suite
l'intensité la trajectoire vers la
distance ça ça va venir à travers
l'enquête qui va prendre un petit peu
plus de temps donc on a un observateur
parce que l'aéroport qui nous
officialisé l'Observatoire
météorologique à l'aéroport qui nous
officialisé qu'une tornade tombée dans
la région le toucher ça dans la région
donc on peut immédiatement confirmer
mais il y a pas de débris encore je
crois de rapporter de ce côté ou de
dommages ça peut être chaud aussi
simplement des milieux agricoles donc il
y a pas d'essence de dommages rapportés
mais on peut quand même observer de
phénomènes
de l'intensité des dommages il y a une
échelle qui est qui est établie pour les
mesurer donc on parle de mirabelles ça
semble pas être très grave comme impact
mais est-ce qu'on sait dans quelle
catégorie quand même se situe la tornade
de Mirabel et celle de tarot
on peut pas tout de suite le savoir
vraiment que les dommages qu'on observe
du côté de toi certainement il y a une
certaine puissance de vente et on
catégorisera probablement parce que on
peut être même en dessous de el-0 en
fonction de la force des vents mais
probablement peut-être même EF1 parce
qu'on a vu des dommages à des toits on a
quand même non plus des voitures virées
à l'envers dans la rue des choses comme
ça donc il est certaine vitesse de vent
qui sont établies en fonction de chaque
et ça vient aussi avec la construction
des bâtiments tous les bâtiments n'ont
pas le même code de construction en
fonction de l'âge aussi du bâtiment ça a
été construit les différentes façons
donc les spécialistes de l'université
d'Ontario qui va se dirige présentement
dans la région qui sont peut-être même
digérés qui évaluent les dommages quand
tu observés les branches les gens qui
ont été cassés et avec ça on peut
inférer parce qu'on va pas on n'a pas
mesurer la vitesse de l'homme on peut
inférer la vitesse des vents dans ces
régions là mais pour les gens de
mirabelle si on rapporte pas de dommage
ça va être très difficile d'établir une
vitesse de vent vous le disiez de ça
prend des dommages pour le constater
vous disiez tous les bâtiments ne sont
pas faites pareil est-ce que quand même
des consignes qui sont à suivre en
général lorsqu'on reçoit sur notre
téléphone par exemple une alerte de
tornade
pour commencer effectivement le code du
bâtiment d'une façon de construire les
bâtiments donc c'est quelque chose qui
doit être suivi par toute personne qui
fait des constructions mais disons que
le code du bâtiment ici n'est pas le
même que en aucun moment ou aux
États-Unis où il y a essentiellement
beaucoup plus autonome ici donc les
codes sont fait différemment en fonction
des dangers des régions maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire lorsqu'une
tendance se présente dans notre région
si on reçoit d'alerte maintenant c'est
de prendre on doit se mettre à l'abri
immédiatement le plus rapidement
possible dans un bâtiment solide le plus
rapidement possible donc si on est chez
nous on va dans le sol idéalement ou au
moins on s'éloigne des murs et des faits
parce qu'on a vu encore aujourd'hui les
projectiles des morceaux de bois qui ont
traversé des murs au s'enfoncer dans la
maison donc c'est un danger même si on
est à l'intérieur on essaie de se mettre
le plus bas possible le plus loin des
fenêtres possibles ou des murs et si on
n'est pas dans une voiture on peut même
rester dans un état dans une maison on
peut rester dans une voiture attachée on
se penche pour éviter des projectiles
qui arriveraient mais la voiture
pourrait aussi se faire souffler par la
tomate donc le mieux c'est vraiment être
à l'intérieur pour protéger donc les
gens camping par exemple on essaie de
trouver à tout le monde on essaie de
prévoir parce que quand on a une veille
de tornade comme le petit matin on peut
anticiper qui risque d'avoir quelque
chose donc on a un plan B on sait
qu'est-ce qu'on devrait faire si jamais
tu matérialise alors quand l'alerte est
lancée on prend action et on fait ce
qu'on peut pour se protéger mais c'est
le goût vous le disiez ce matin on avait
une veille de tornade c'est ça ça a cru
au niveau d'alerte de tornade on en est
où là pour la région de Montréal et le
reste du Québec
on présente pour la région de Montréal
même les du côté de l'Ontario le tout
est complètement terminé je voulais
Montréal il y a encore certaines
cellules qui sont menaçantes mais je ne
crois pas que des alertes qui restent
quelques élèves
élevé bientôt maintenant beaucoup plus
pour la région de Trois-Rivières s'est
rendu un coin je crois 5 ans de la
Peyrade où là on a un alerte le tournage
qui est envoyé qui est présente
actuellement donc encore de la rotation
dans les nuages anticipés à travers les
radars on peut lapercevoir et donc on
averti les gens avec l'alerte que cette
région là est vulnérable à l'Éternel
mais ailleurs lorsque les orages
violents même si c'est pas Ternat on
peut quand même recevoir de gros grêlons
de fortes pluies qui peuvent causer des
refoulements des goûts on peut aussi
avoir de fortes terrains qui peuvent
quand même faire les dommages si c'est
pas une tornade donc les alertes sont
quand même là pour toujours prévenir les
gens que le danger est imminent il y a
eu une tornade au Québec pour l'instant
il y en a eu 26 l'année dernière c'est
un peu moins du quart du nombre total au
pays et est-ce qu'il y en a plus que par
le passé monsieur le goût dans l'est du
pays
bon c'est la première disons qu'on est
en pleine à la saison où ça pourrait se
produire tu pourrais en avoir d'autres
on leur souhaite pas trop non plus c'est
évident mais l'année passée une année
assez active on peut percevoir si on
regarde les chiffres peut-être des
dernières années une augmentation mais
c'est pas parce qu'il y a plus de
tornade vraiment de des nouveaux moyens
technologiques pour les découvrir les
repérer dans les milieux forestiers
peut-être très éloignés qu'on n'aurait
pas perçu dans les années 80 par exemple
donc des nouveaux moyens technologiques
les réseaux sociaux à la diffusé
l'information aussi donc on peut
recevoir beaucoup d'informations comme
ça des nouveaux moyens pour avoir des
chiffres plus élevés mais ça veut pas
dire que le phénomène se crée de plus en
plus en fait à travers les changements
climatiques il y a pas vraiment d'études
qui anticipent vraiment d'augmentation
par rapport aux tornades mettant les
phénomènes climatiques extrêmes
pourraient augmenter et devrait
augmenter on le perçoit déjà avec des
pluies plus abondantes comme on a reçu
au début de la semaine les grands
torrents qui ont impacté différentes et
rivières et plan d'eau ça c'est vraiment
une conséquence des changements
climatiques c'est quelque chose qui est
en branle donc on perçoit une certaine
augmentation on l'anticipe aussi pour la
suite mais l'Éternel on prévoit pas
nécessairement de changements aussi il y
a il est vraiment trop difficile à
prévoir pour l'instant mais tant mieux
si mon logo je rappelle que vous êtes
météorologue pour Environnement Canada
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce soir